five the fetus is not a person but a  potential person answer no he is again a  distinct human entity if this is not the  definition of a person then none of us  are persons also even if he is a  potential person it doesn't  automatically follow that we should  destroy him do you believe that all  non-persons can be killed what if i  decapitated a bald eagle how would you  feel about that you see you're wrong  that the unborn child isn't a person by  definition he is but even if you were  right you'd still be wrong that's how  wrong you are six women have  reproductive rights answer this one i  agree with nobody should ever be forced  to reproduce but birth is not  reproduction conception is reproduction  by the time the abortion is procured  reproduction has already occurred